[Music]
hi everyone i'm anushari bostava and
today we're going to be talking about
vertex ai's automl by google cloud as a
recap automl is a no code solution that
allows us to create high quality custom
models with minimal effort and ml
expertise with automl you can train a
model for different data types such as
image text tabular or even video data
today we're going to look at a concrete
example with natural language
understanding for text data
automl natural language allows you to
perform supervised learning which
involves training a computer to
recognize patterns from labeled data
using supervised learning you can train
a custom model to recognize content that
you care about and text
the use cases for this flavor of
automela include entity extraction
sentiment analysis and text
classification
what sort of problems can you solve with
these options
entity extraction allows you to create a
model that expects a document for known
entities reference in the document and
then label those entities in the text so
you can use this for example to extract
key players such as people company
locations in a structured manner from
news articles
a good use for sentiment analysis is
when you want to identify the prevailing
emotional opinion within text
specifically determine a writer's
attitude as positive negative or neutral
and last but not least text
classification and that is what we are
going to do today
let's say i'm working at a company and
we just launched a new version of our
app we're starting to scale up and we
really want to meet our customers needs
we are thrilled that our app is growing
explosively but it's getting harder to
properly route our incoming user reports
and we spend a lot of time triaging what
are either bug reports billing issues or
feedback you could use a pre-trained api
for nlp
however the general model does not
understand the specific nuances we need
in this scenario
if your text consists of news articles
or other content you want to categorize
or if you want to discover the sentiment
of your examples the pre-trained natural
language api is worth trying
but if your text examples don't fit
neatly into sentiment based or the
vertical topic based classification
scheme available in the natural language
api and you want to use your own labels
instead it's worth experimenting with a
custom classifier to see if it fits your
needs
just like in our use case
so let's go into vertex ai and see
exactly how we build this model we can
then integrate into our feedback system
here we are in the vertex ai console we
have our data set already with the
feedback we've already collected and
most importantly labeled then we go into
the trainings tab select a couple
options automl will split the data for
me between training test and validation
and it's off to the races
the default for training
is 80 of your data but you can manually
adjust the division if needed
the vast majority of your data should be
in the training set this is the data
your model sees during training it's
used to learn the parameters of the
model namely the weights of the
connections between the nodes in the
neural network
the validation set sometimes also called
the dev set is also used during the
training process
after the model learning framework
incorporates the training data during
each iteration of the training process
it uses the model's performance on the
validation set to tune the model
the test set is not involved during the
training process
after the model has completed its
training automl natural language uses
the test set as a challenge for your
model
the performance of your model on the
test set is intended to give you an idea
of how your model will perform on
real-world data
once the model is done training we can
check out our model here in the models
tab we click on the model name and there
are a few mechanisms for us to evaluate
the model such as the precision and
recall the confusion matrix which shows
how often the model classified each
label correctly shows in blue
the test and deploy tab allows us to
deploy our model to a rest endpoint so
we can then easily call it from a web or
mobile app
it also lets us make sample predictions
here from within the ui
let's try out a sample
the loading times are so slow now on my
pixel 4.
the model correctly identified this as a
bug report
let's do one more just for fun
thank you for this release the new
features are great
we can see the model predicted this as
general feedback with a high confidence
score
now let's say we want to use this model
from a phone or web app so right here in
vertex ai we can see the python code we
would need to call this cloud hosted
model from our apps
client libraries and other languages are
available too
i can repeat what we just did in the
console making predictions
programmatically in my code and then
make decisions in my app based on the
model's output
so there you go now you can see how as
developers we can easily build machine
learning models to solve our problems
and directly integrate them into our
apps and services all without a phd
check out the guide on getting started
with automl natural language processing
and let us know what you think
[Music]